a lot of what we've been discussing
about focusing on small moments focusing
on rest focusing on how people connect
with each other those are big parts of
this sub-genre and they're not
necessarily focused on giant Space
Battles often they feel a little bit
like a drawing room melodrama although
there are often huge battles that are
happening like in the background and we
know about them and they're informing
the events that are going on but that is
part of admitting that the future might
be okay is acknowledging that actually
these small moments in our lives really
do matter you know the moment when you
like win the big case or write the big
book or like win the battle yeah those
are great moments but actually the stuff
that you remember like that's going to
the beach with your friends when you
just like said work for the day
we're gonna get high on the beat like
that's just as memorable and just as
important
um and I think that this fits into
um our final thing that I want to talk
about which is ambient queerness in
fiction which is also part of cozy
fiction and it's also part of imagining
um a more balanced future so
let's talk about it
um for me I mean it's so very simple
um coming at this as a queer woman I I
don't know why I would write a future
that didn't have people like me and mine
in it
um and I I think that
um though regardless of which series I'm
talking about because I've done this in
all of these having a future in which
you don't have to come out you don't
have to struggle
with
um knowing your place finding your Niche
understanding who you are being accepted
people are never in danger for who they
love how they present
um how they live their lives
um and even though
bad things happen in my books it's not
gonna be that and the reason for that is
because I want
um queer readers to be able to pick up
my work and know that I am not going to
hurt them in that way the real world
hurts us enough
in that way
um if we are actually going to believe
that the future is good that obstacle as
far as I'm concerned needs to be removed
from it that doesn't mean we shouldn't
tell stories about queer pain that
doesn't mean we shouldn't tell stories
about queer tragedy but in my work for
my part
um what I find to be
the most powerful thing I can do when I
am scared when I am hurting
is to write a world in which that kind
of hurt doesn't exist anymore and it's
it's not hard to do
I think we've both been both proven that
in our in our stuff that you can just
exist as you are and it doesn't have to
be as difficult as it is yeah I think
the thing that I really like about what
I'm calling ambient queerness which can
mean having characters having situations
it's not just about having queer
character like characters who are gay or
lesbian or bisexual it's also about
imagining different ways that people
might have relationships with each other
they might be polyamorous they might be
asexual they might have like one gender
today and like six genders tomorrow they
might not even think of gender as an
important binary like if you have a
character who's a train like gender is
not really a thing right like the train
is having a romance with a cat so like
okay there's your genders cat and train
um and then of course you know now you
know where the cat bus comes from in My
Neighbor Totoro
um that is I serious
I did that okay I did that for you
um but I so it's about imagining like
radical new forms of otherness that
aren't demonized that are just like fun
and cozy and and that's been baked into
science fiction from the jump if you are
talking about a a genre in which we have
aliens we have robots we have sentient
trains uh and these are all par for the
course it just becomes ridiculous that
you wouldn't have
all these different structures of these
social structures of gender family sex
all the rest of it it it's part and
parcel of the of this style of
Storytelling uh and so it lends itself
very naturally to just being a place
where you can explore all these things
and make it as easy as pie
um now it's one of the things I love
about it so much yeah